you taught me that people aren't
supposed to ask you for pictures while
you're eating yeah I just don't get it
yeah just like the bathroom too I've had
dudes right come into the bathroom and
my Bros have been there too and I'm like
dick in my hand taking a pit dude let me
get a photo yeah wait outside the
restroom we were at the UFC in Vegas
Steve was pissing in the urinal and some
guy came and put the phone in front of
him while he was peeing in the urinal
I've never seen Steve get so pissed
before my life dude you like backhanded
the phone out of his hand you were so
pissed that's pretty crazy I got
physical with the guy at a UFC fight
I'm your biggest ever not there you're
testosterone levels you were like for
sure